when disney acquired rival studio 21st
century fox in 2019
it allowed them to make the fantastic
four films available on the disney plus
streaming platform
when it launched that november however
in august 2021
eagle-eyed fans noticed that 2005's
fantastic four
had been quietly removed from disney
plus why
released in 2005 fantastic four was
panned by critics with an unfortunate 27
rating on rotten tomatoes the film
starred marvel cinematic universe's
chris evans as johnny storm
along with jessica alba as sue storm
johan griffith as reed richards and
michael chiklis as ben grimm fantastic
four was eagerly anticipated by fans of
the comics but was largely
perceived as missing the mark especially
disappointing was the film's depiction
of iconic marvel villain dr doom
still even with this poor critical
response the film was a financial
success
earning enough for fox to greenlight a
sequel rise of the silver
surfer this second installment didn't
fare much better with critics though
although the 2005 fantastic four has
disappeared from disney plus
rise of the silver surfer is still
available on the streaming service
the 2015 reboot of fantastic four
starring another future mcu star
michael b jordan is also available on
the platform
as part of what disney calls the marvel
legacy collection now that the 2005 film
has disappeared though
will these movies also be leaving disney
plus with constantly changing contracts
and deals in the industry
it seems likely that every marvel movie
ever made will eventually find a home on
disney plus
there is probably a contractual reason
why the 2005 fantastic four disappeared
but it will probably find its way back
to the streamer after visiting some
other platforms
after all disney is eager to make its
brands synonymous with all things marvel
as demonstrated by their commitment to
their partnership with sony
when spider-man joined the mcu in 2016's
captain america
civil war it was a huge deal sony owned
the rights to peter parker
and all related characters but was
essentially leasing the character to
marvel's creative team
while keeping most of the profits in
april 2021 the companies furthered the
deal
ensuring that tom holland's spider-man
films would soon be available on disney
plus
after previously being available only on
netflix spider-man fully joining the mcu
was a long time coming and
fans are equally as excited to see the
fantastic four stake their claim in the
universe
big fan of spider-man yeah we'll talk
about it later just hey everyone
good job meanwhile while we're pretty
sure that the 2005 fantastic four film
will reappear on disney plus at some
point in the future
mcu fans can also look forward to
marvel's first family making a big
cinematic comeback
a fantastic four project is in the works
for the marvel cinematic universe
with spider-man director john watts
slated to direct
it's likely the film will be hitting the
screen sometime in 2023
although no further information is yet
available that of course hasn't stopped
fans from speculating about what an mcu
fantastic four could look like
many marvel devotees are dead set on
john krasinski
joining the universe as reed richards
with his real-life wife emily blunt as
sue storm
other popular fan castings for mr
fantastic include
i zombie star rahul coley and the good
place leading man william jackson harper
however none of the actors whose names
have been tossed around have admitted to
speaking to the studio about roles
although coley at least has openly
campaigned for the role and marvel
hasn't released any information about
casting
that said the studio is laying the
groundwork for the fantastic four's
arrival
we met a variant of kang the conqueror
in the loki finale
although he was introduced in that
episode only as he who remains
as comic fans know kang is commonly
thought to be a descendant or
relative of reed richards kang is
already set to appear under his true
name this time
in ant-man and the wasp quantum mania in
the meantime while you wait for the
fantastic four to make their arrival in
the mcu
and for the 2005 film to return to
disney plus you can still re-watch rise
of the silver
surfer anytime you want check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about marvel are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you